all right tons of people emailing me
saying David you aren't covering the
blockbuster DNC lawsuit cover it this is
huge well I'm going to cover it and I
want to explain to you why it isn't
getting much coverage there is a sort of
corporate media blackout on this lawsuit
but there's a reason why and I'm going
to explain it to you and the reason why
is that the lawsuit is going nowhere and
I know people are going to hear me say
this don't say David how dare you how
dare you say it's going nowhere
there is a major story that you may have
seen floating around online and the
major story is a corporate media
blackout on a DNC lawsuit well what are
the merits of the lawsuit what are the
facts of the case a lawsuit has been
filed against the Democratic National
Committee for their alleged favoring of
Hillary Clinton over Bernie Sanders
during the 2016 primary this has been
filed as a class action in US district
court by residents of 45 states against
both the DNC and specifically against
Debbie wasserman-schultz the then DNC
chair for quote intentional willful
wanton and malicious conduct in
violating article 5 section 4 of the
Democratic National Committee's Charter
there are three classes of plaintiffs
here donors to the DNC donors to Bernie
Sanders's campaign and all registered
Democrats on April 25th the court held a
hearing on a motion to dismiss the DNC's
lawyers argued we have every right to
pick candidates in the back rooms and
favor candidates if that's what we want
to do there has been very little
coverage of it the lawyers for the DNC
are saying that Sanders supporters were
aware that the primaries were
effectively rigged and that neutrality
is a political promise that cannot be
enforced by a court basically the
argument from DNC lawyers is this is our
internal Charter we're not legally bound
to it
thus the lawsuit is bogus this is an
affirmative defense right rather than
denying that they rigged the primaries
or were you know pushing the scale for
one candidate over another there
saying there's nothing stopping the DNC
from helping one candidate win over
another why isn't this going to get much
coverage because the DNC is basically
right I am the first person to tell you
yeah the DNC did favor Hillary Clinton
they favored her they did they made
decisions with regards to the debate
scheduling and number of debates timing
etc that was meant to help Hillary
Clinton in many ways they were
strategizing together with the Hillary
Clinton campaign against Bernie Sanders
but whatever Democrats internal Charter
says that they are supposed to be a
neutral arbiter of the primary unless
individual donors can prove that some
kind of real fraud was committed which
even if we colloquially think that that
could be demonstrated is very hard to do
legally this is going nowhere so I'm not
defending corporate media for not
covering this but I'm explaining to you
why this is going nowhere people are
going to be mad at me for saying this
it's not going anywhere yeah well I mean
it's easy to forget sometimes that the
Democratic Party is a private
institution so you're right they don't
have to adhere to their own charter but
I think the people bringing this
class-action lawsuit are looking for
some sort of symbolic victory I think
that's what they're able to get because
if the DNC's lawyers have to make
concessions of the fact that yeah we did
rig this and Bernie Sanders supporters
knew about it I think that's good enough
I think that's sort of a win in and of
itself you think I don't know that there
are too many of the people that are
emailing me saying David you've got to
cover this in corporate media won't
cover it I don't know that they're going
to be happy with the symbolic victory
because they're still emailing me even
though they already got the symbolic
victory right I could see them wanting
to have some sort of repercussions when
it comes to debbie Wasserman Schultz
okay but what do you want the Democratic
Party to be fined and thus your ability
to run effective candidates in 2018 and
2020 to be hindered that's it that's a
fair question and I don't know the
answer to that and I I want to be clear
I agree with the allegations made by the
lawsuit I just don't believe that the
lawsuit itself is going to do anything
and obviously the Democratic Party isn't
that Democratic super-delegates right I
mean the ability for individuals to
overrule large swath
some Democratic voters we knew that it
wasn't really democratic to begin with
and that's not a surprise at all but
that if you disagree about where the
lawsuit will go let me know right and
then I'll follow up well luckily when
Debbie wasserman-schultz was ousted they
replaced her with someone who was
completely impartial being Donna Brazile
yes Donna Brazile came in and then
everything was fine